articles un peu bruts et neutres Je ne
vais pas être neutre ce que j'aime chez toi
Joe's 3d, c'est que c'est un outil artistique
à utiliser dans le film, vous savez qu'il a
en fait beaucoup d'éléments de narration
, c'est littéralement comme repeindre
votre film  parce que cela affecte toute l'
expérience, nous avons donc passé un bon moment à
convertir GI Joe, nous avons en fait tourné sur un
film, nous avons donc obtenu la texture et ressenti
le grain et quand nous l'avons pris en 3D, nous
devons littéralement prendre chaque image et la
découper, nous avons plus de 700  des artistes
qui découpent chaque objet et le
séparent les uns des autres et
nous donnent une expérience que nous obtenons pour
contrôler pleinement les yeux de serpent jinx il est temps de
rejoindre le combat c'était une
scène extraordinaire que nous avons passé probablement plus de temps
que n'importe quelle scène dans le  film sur lequel était
notre combat de ninja du côté des
montagnes himalayennes et il résiste
à toute image d'action où vous êtes à des
milliers de pieds du sol, donc
cela accentue vraiment l'expérience de
traiter afin que cette scène dans  en particulier en est
un dont tout le monde va parler
il y a des plans où ils sautent de ce
pont et c'est un super plan en 2d c'est
génial mais en 3d votre corps
ressemble littéralement à des secousses un peu vous avez ce
sentiment de vertige qui était une surprise dont vous avez
peur  des hauteurs qui sont définitivement une
douche vous allez whoa exactement nous avons dit
très clairement à toutes les personnes impliquées lorsque
nous convertissons en 3ds qu'il fallait avoir
le temps et les ressources pour le faire
correctement à la fois pour Tinley est-ce que cette séquence
va être un coup de pied bien sûr précieux
c'est  très semblable à un processus d'animation ou à
un processus d'effets visuels et que vous faites des
itérations, vous pouvez pousser la longueur d'un
espace ou vous pouvez pousser ensemble la
prox tenta de nombreux personnages mais chaque
fois que vous faites quelque chose, il y a une
contre-réaction ailleurs dans  le
cadre pour que n'importe quel cadre puisse passer par
20 30 40 itérations et nous étions assis là à
regarder chaque image de notre film petit à
petit les détenteurs de pièces de monnaie notre deuxième 100 fois
les missiles était vraiment intéressant
les choses deviennent de
plus en plus grandes en 3D, les missiles ont commencé à
paraître de plus en plus petits, vous savez,
alors nous sommes comme bien ce n'est pas la
bonne chose parce que l'enfer sur terre est
sur le point de se produire avec ces missiles, ils
doivent avoir une mise à l'échelle John avait ceci
l'idée de prendre le missile en dehors du
cadre vraiment et donc en tant que public,
vous êtes assis ici et le missile passe en quelque
sorte juste au-dessus de votre tête et de votre visage,
alors vous sentez vraiment qu'il envoie une échelle
et ce n'est pas quelque chose que nous aurions pu
faire en 2d
chaque petite chose que nous découvrons
dicte d'autres choses comme le son comme
tout à coup quand vous avez tout ce qui
vient du côté de votre tête maintenant le son
a une idée comme oh nous pouvons faire
voler cette chose juste à côté de votre oreille
ce qui était si étonnant pour moi était  à quel point
la technologie est améliorée, vous savez que la
conversion a eu une mauvaise réputation à un
moment donné, mais c'est un
jeu de balle totalement différent maintenant, la technologie a obtenu
cette bonne expérience 3D a été une expérience
vraiment incroyable  ience, nous sommes une vaste
aventure mondiale qui vous emmène des
montagnes de l'Himalaya au Japon, Washington
DC, au désert et au Pakistan, nous
voulions vraiment engloutir le public de notre
monde et avec ce contrôle,
dimensionnez-le lorsque le public
voit le film ne le ressentez pas  aventure
ils se sentiront comme wow nous venons de
faire le tour du monde GI Joes GI Joes ne sont pas
ces petites choses sur le
sol de votre chambre, ils sont plus grands que nature le rocher
est juste devant vous Bruce Willis est
juste à vos côtés des yeux de serpent comme  son
armement et ses coups de pied là-bas et
vous en faites partie, donc je pense que cette
expérience en est une que les fans et les
gens qui n'ont jamais entendu parler de GI Joe
vont vraiment vraiment aimer conduire comme si
vous l'aviez volé vous avez besoin d'un nouveau slogan
vous